en una firma histórica de emiratos
árabes unidos y bahrein normalizan
relaciones con israel en plena campaña
presidencial en eeuu donald trump fue el
anfitrión de la ceremonia donde quedaron
sellados los acuerdos de abraham trump
aseguró que estos pactos servirán para
conseguir la paz en medio oriente
el opositor ruso alexéi navalni se
recupera y planea regresar a rusia en
una señal de su mejoría naval ni publicó
un mensaje en redes sociales
el activista estuvo en un coma inducido
hasta la semana pasada y según los
médicos alemanes que lo asisten fue
expuesto a un agente nervioso de la
familia del novillo
aproximadamente uno de cada diez casos
de kobe 19 en el mundo es de un
trabajador de la salud que se contagió
mientras laboraba según el consejo
internacional de enfermería en madrid'
médicos y enfermeras protestaron para
exigir mejores condiciones
hola cómo están bienvenidos a las
noticias aquí en france 24 mi nombre es
alan austria empezamos en la casa blanca
donde a 50 días de las elecciones
presidenciales de eeuu donald trump fue
el anfitrión de una ceremonia histórica
en la que los ministros de relaciones
exteriores de emiratos árabes unidos y
bahrein sellaron los acuerdos de
normalización de las relaciones con
israel al hacerlo las dos naciones del
golfo pérsico revierten décadas de
enemistad con israel sobre su disputa
con los palestinos
trump prometió que más naciones del
medio oriente harán lo mismo
es un mes de cambios sin precedentes en
el panorama político de oriente medio el
presidente de donald trump les dio la
bienvenida a la casa blanca al primer
ministro israelí benjamín netanyahu y a
los ministros de relaciones exteriores
de emiratos árabes unidos y bahrein un
día que todos los involucrados
calificaron de histórico ya que firmaron
acuerdos para la normalización de los
lazos entre israel y estas dos naciones
son solo el tercer y cuarto estado árabe
en firmar estos acuerdos después de
egipto en 1979 y jordania en 1994
estamos aquí para cambiar el curso de la
historia después de décadas de división
y conflicto marcamos el amanecer de un
nuevo medio oriente
este día es un giro en la historia
presagia un nuevo amanecer de pasos
durante miles de años el pueblo judío ha
rezado por la paz y es por eso que hoy
estamos llenos de una gratitud tan
profunda
trump dijo que bajo estos acuerdos estos
tres países establecerán embajadas
intercambiarán diplomáticos y cooperarán
en una amplia gama de temas incluidos el
comercio y la seguridad
vivirlos también marca un realineamiento
regional estratégico contra irán sin
embargo estos pactos se firmaron sin una
resolución sobre la disputa de larga
data de israel con los palestinos pese a
esto el ministro de relaciones
exteriores de los emiratos árabes unidos
agradeció israel por suspender la
anexión planeada del territorio
palestino según acordaron ambas naciones
el mes pasado a cambio de la
normalización la decisión esta es una
decisión que refuerza lo que compartimos
para lograr un futuro mejor para las
generaciones venideras generations'
stockham no está claro como el plan de
paz de washington para oriente medio
procederá sin la cooperación de la
autoridad palestina que interpreta estos
acuerdos como una traición de la
posición panárabe que exige que israel
se retire de la ocupada cisjordania y
acepte a palestina como estado
en su cuenta en instagram el opositor
ruso alexéi navalni publicó una foto en
la que sale junto a su familia en el
hospital en berlín alemania donde se
recupera tras un presunto envenenamiento
andrew amaya nos cuenta más en el
siguiente informe
esta foto es la prueba de la
recuperación del líder de la oposición
rusa alexéi navalni por petición de la
familia fue trasladado a berlín en
estado de coma en un avión medicalizado
desde rusia donde logró sobrevivir a un
envenenamiento en el mensaje en avant y
expresa su alegría por haber podido
respirar por primera vez durante un día
entero sin ayuda de equipos médicos hola
soy naval team los extraño a todos
todavía no sé mucho de lo que pasa pero
ayer pude respirar todo el día por mi
cuenta en realidad por mi cuenta no use
ninguna ayuda externa ni siquiera la más
simple válvula en mi garganta es un
proceso asombroso subestimado por muchos
lo recomiendo la zona serie de análisis
los médicos alemanes llegaron a la
conclusión de que el opositor ruso fue
envenenado con la sustancia tóxica del
grupo noise ok los resultados fueron
confirmados posteriormente por
laboratorios en francia y suecia el caso
de naval ni ha provocado tensión entre
berlín y moscú en varias ocasiones
alemania le ha pedido al kremlin que
ayude a aclarar lo ocurrido en una
conversación telefónica el ministro de
relaciones
exteriores de rusia serguéi lávrov y su
homólogo alemán heiko maas que alemania
deje de politizar la situación en torno
a naval ni en un comunicado el
ministerio de relaciones exteriores ruso
aseguró que están listos para cooperar
en la investigación
un 10 por ciento de los casi 30 millones
de casos de kobe 19 registrados en el
planeta corresponden al personal médico
según un estudio presentado hoy por el
consejo internacional de enfermería
veamos se trata de 3 millones de
trabajadores sanitarios que se han
contagiado de kobe 19 además indica el
informe al menos 1.000 enfermeros y
enfermeras han muerto en 44 países una
cifra que puede ser mucho mayor dada la
falta de datos en numerosas redes
sanitarias
y precisamente en la capital de españa
los trabajadores de la salud de madrid
protestaron contra la falta de apoyo de
las autoridades y exigieron mejores
condiciones de trabajo nos lo cuenta
matías a raíz
el resurgimiento de casos de kobe 19
llega acompañado de un aumento de las
reivindicaciones las enfermeras y los
médicos protestaron frente al hospital
gregorio marañón de madrid en contra de
las autoridades locales a las que exigen
mayores recursos españa es el país con
más casos en europa superando ya el
medio millón y la inminente llegada de
la temporada invernal hace temer un
nuevo colapso en el sistema sanitario
es que va a colapsar tuvimos un mes de
marzo abril mayo que colapsó por por una
pandemia por un kobe pero el problema
ahora es de recursos humanos ya se nos
va a juntar el rebrote que sea mayor o
menor va a llegar con con la lista de
espera que espera ser atendida con un
problema humano el personal va a
enfermar si estamos así en el mes de
septiembre no queremos imaginar cómo
vamos a estar en el mes de diciembre que
es realmente la temporada alta de la
sanidad un informe del consejo de
supervisión de la preparación global un
órgano independiente lanzado por la
organización mundial de la salud y el
banco mundial denuncia que sus
advertencias fueron ignoradas
advertimos que el mundo estaba mal
preparado para tal pandemia trágicamente
y catastróficamente hemos visto
realizado en nuestro peor temor el
impacto del cob y 19 es aún peor de lo
que habíamos previsto pero las medidas
que pedimos el año pasado aún no se han
tomado sin esas medidas el mundo
permanece vulnerable
el panel advierte que si los gobiernos
no actúan una próxima pandemia no es
sólo inevitable sino que será aún más
devastadora la organización mundial de
la salud informó el domingo de un
aumento récord en un día de los casos de
kobe 19 en todo el mundo con un total de
más de 300.000 infecciones en 24 horas
y mire finalizamos con la pesadilla que
continúa para miles de refugiados en las
islas griegas después del incendio en el
campo de memoria ahora los refugiados
rechazan ingresar al nuevo campamento
provisional ante la falta de garantías
mientras las autoridades griegas están
intentando persuadirlos alegando que es
un requisito para poder tramitar las
solicitudes de asilo este martes las
autoridades arrestaron a cinco migrantes
señalados de ser responsables de haber
iniciado este incendio marina esta riña
nos amplíen en el siguiente informe
bajo la disyuntiva de permanecer
durmiendo a la intemperie o ingresar
bajo ecuación al nuevo campamento de
karate así se encuentran miles de
refugiados varados en la isla de lesbos
casi una semana después del incendio que
arrasó con moria el mayor campo de
refugiados de europa este marte las
autoridades griegas han detenido a cinco
migrantes por su presunta implicación en
el siniestro tristes temores los
pirómanos de moria están en custodia son
cinco jóvenes extranjeros estamos
buscando uno más a los demás en las
inmediaciones de moria los refugiados se
rehúsan a ingresar en el nuevo campo y
están siendo persuadidos a través de
folletos informativos por las
autoridades griegas que aseguran que es
la única vía para solicitar asilo
y es el infierno número dos yo ya estaba
en la cárcel porque estar en moria es
estar en la cárcel así que vengo aquí
veo gente coches entrando no no quiero
no entraré ahí
esa crisis humanitaria en el seno de la
unión europea sigue exacerbando las
tensiones con los locales que se oponen
a que se establezca un nuevo campamento
para maestros
el cuadro es realmente terrible las
cosas están empeorando y si terminan el
campo y el tiempo pasa lo quemaran de
nuevo esta gente quiere irse deben
ponerlos en botes y llevarlos a donde
quieran ir porque los mantienen aquí
cuanto más tiempo se queden más se
sienten como prisioneros porque no los
dejan salir fuera como ven la función al
fin ya tiene fin en medio de los
llamados del gobierno griego a la
solidaridad del bloque europeo con lo
que es un problema común alemania
anunció que acogerá mil 553 refugiados
exhaustos del abandono institucional de
años
pues así llegamos al final de esta
emisión les agradecemos mucho su
compañía y los invitamos a que sigan con
las noticias en france24 ya que se cuide
cuídese mucho del hobbit 19
[Música]